Daniel Friedman: Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Active inference
Institute quarterly roundtable number two
in 2023.
It's June 30, 2023, and this is going to
be our quarterly updates and ways that
you can participate at the institute and
in the active ecosystem.
So welcome to the active inference
institute.
We're a participant battori online
institute that is communicating, learning
, and practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links on this page
and note that we'll be transitioning our
emails over from activeinference@gmail.com
towards Active Inference Institute
domains.
This is recorded in an archive Livestream,
, so please provide us with feedback so
that we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome, and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams today in the
quarterly meeting number two of the year.
.
We'll start at the institute scale, give
some updates at the institute level, and
then we'll look a little bit deeper into
primarily education, but also research.
And then I'll have some closing thoughts
by way of a presidential address about
where we're at with active inference.
And if you're watching live, please write
comments and questions in the live chat
and we will look to address those during.
.
Okay, so starting with the institute
scale, some updates coming from the
institute.
Here's one way that we can visualize the
active inference institute in June 2023.
We are within the active inference
ecosystem as well as within other
ecosystems, and we have a nested
structure.
Alex, would you like to describe this?
Alex Vyatkin: Yeah, I think for these
moments, it's great to see this structure
and understand what is actually in place
and working and acting and adapting.
Alex: And from very beginning we consider
it from perspective of systems thinking
and from perspective of active inference.
We always think about some kind of nested
and hierarchical structure which can be
builded and structured accordingly.
So having it right now embodied, it's
great to see it totally agree.
Daniel: At the institute scale where
these first updates are going to come
from, we have the officers, the board of
directors, and the scientific advisory
board.
We have two organizational units which
steward the development and support
participation in projects.
And projects and learning groups are
really where it happens on the ground.
And so we're going to talk a lot more
about these.
But this is the nesting and our own
relationship with the ecosystem.
Another way to see this is in terms of
people and positions at the institute.
So starting from the left, we have casual
engagement with our products and services
into the niche.
So this might be the very video that you'
're listening to or watching right now.
It could be the transcript of this video
that you're reading.
It might be the active inference ontology.
.
It might be the active block, for
instance, software package.
There's all these different open source
products and services that we provide to
the niche.
And one moment you will decide to
participate in a project or a learning
group, and that can be more towards the
learning, more towards the doing and
leveraging your contributions at the
institute.
And some participants will choose to
solidify their participation through
volunteering or engaging with the
internship program, both of which are new
and really excitingly.
Developing well and then we haven't
listed any names of the many of you who
are in all of these different stages.
And you may want to play another role or
another position in the Institute, such
as the Scientific Advisory Board, board
of Directors or the officers.
So a lot of appreciation and thanks to
everybody who's shown and not shown on
this slide.
We are really appreciative of how you all
show up for the institute.
Alex, want to add anything on that?
Alex: Yeah, even from this slide, we can
see that a lot of people already involved
in activity and provide great insights
and different perspective and backgrounds
and experience.
And yes, a lot of people not shown here,
but we know them through our community
platforms and so on.
So you can see this progress in terms of
participation in activities and that's
also great progress.
Daniel: All right, moving on.
We are excited that for our third applied
active inference symposium to be held in
August, we will have the theme of
enacting ecosystems of shared
intelligence, active inference as a
cognitive kernel.
We have a really broad and global co
organizer team, which is very exciting.
So thanks to everybody who's in the co
organizing team for this symposium, we're
just getting started on the organization.
.
So in the coming days and weeks, we'll be
providing more information on
participating in a more formal call for
presenters.
However, if you're listening to this
message now and you are really excited to
do a presentation or a workshop or
mentorship and be a part of the active
inference ecosystem, then please reach
out to us.
Alex, anything you want to add here?
Alex: But actually, yes, I think I can
remember that there will be a third
symposium and it's cool that we have that
yearly written for this type of activity
and hopefully this event bring us and for
people who will participate, new insights,
, connections, and ground for future
developments.
Cool.
Daniel: All right, just to summarize and
update a few of the institute level
programs.
So volunteering at the institute, it's a
way to engage.
It is just making it that much easier to
get involved with one or more projects
and to start to get that recognition from
the institute, understanding your
contributions and also on your own resume
or your own work history or your
portfolio.
Volunteering is really an incredible way
to learn by doing.
If you want to apply or learn about
organizational active inference or if you
want to think about communication as
active inference education in the context
of active inference gripper and the
gripped if you want a perspective swap
and see it multiple ways.
Learning by doing on a project through
volunteering, we hope, is a really unique
opportunity.
And what you do will and does really
matter.
So if you're taking notes on the margin
of some paper or if you're developing
lists that you felt like help your
onboarding into active inference, you can
make a leveraged contribution by sharing
that kind of information.
Or if you're not quite sure what type of
contribution or the impact it would have,
we can help find that kind of a niche for
you.
The internship program is being a
volunteer but wanting a little bit more
structure around that.
We have about 20 currently active interns
from all around the world, different
backgrounds, levels of technical
familiarity with the active inference,
ranging from truly some of the people who
I believe are experts, to people who just
found out about active inference and
wanted to use this program to accelerate
their learning a lot.
Also in the last weeks and months I would
like to commend the two individuals who
know who they are who have completed
their internship.
This has really been a great honor to
work with you, both of you, and to those
who are still active, I look forward to
seeing those updates and continuing to
work with you.
The internship consists of learning,
doing and also mentorship and
facilitation.
So interns tend to participate in one or
more course or textbook group or maybe
help out with some live streams.
Interns engage on projects and that is
usually a minimum of two projects.
One is hosted at the Institute.
So some of the projects that we'll look
at later in this roundtable but then also
most of the interns have a personal or
background research agenda.
So sometimes they make very small
contributions to an institute project but
they're working really diligently on
their dissertation or on their hobby
project.
Other times it's most of the contribution
to the Institute project and then a
little bit of self guided research and we
try to provide our interns with support
over multiple spatial and temporal scales.
.
In terms of our engagement in the broader
digital cyberphysical niche, we continue
to grow on our different platforms and
channels, though these are just proxy
measures in our discord podcast, Twitter
and YouTube as well as mailing lists.
So we continue to communicate out to
those who want to hear.
Here's the big picture on Institute
activities and you can find this
information at the activities page that's
listed here.
At the top we have type of project
publication live streams such as the one
happening right now and the active
inference journal which picks up when the
live stream hits stop and transcribes and
curates publishes that transcript which
we'll talk more about.
So live streams and journal are a great
pair in the active block for instance
project we continue to build the soft and
hard skills associated with generative
modeling in the active inference
tradition.
And so we use the complex Adaptive
systems modeling framework Cadcad to
implement different active inference
generative models.
This is a really great place.
A lot of discussions about modeling,
robotics and embodied.
JF Kotcher continues to offer his
expertise and updates from this really
incredible project where real Lego robots
are implementing symbolic active
inference.
So thanks, JF, for hosting this project
the way you do in the active inference
ontology.
We continue to refine and update the
active inference ontology, which is the
real language that we speak, whether it
happens to be deployed in English or
visually or in a programming language or
however, the active inference ontology is
how we're communicating and we develop
that and offer it as a service to the
niche.
In this project, we have multiple ongoing
learning groups which we'll talk more
about soon.
But we have a textbook group with Par et
al.
The 2022 active inference textbook.
We have Sanjeev Namjoshi, who's writing a
really incredible work that will be a
textbook published as Fundamentals of
Active Inference.
And we're alpha testing along with Sanjiv
and right there alongside him.
So thanks, Sanjiv, for bringing this work
in progress to the institute and to
really sticking with the trouble.
This is going to be an incredible product.
.
And we have two courses, one on physics
as information processing and one on
active inference for the social sciences,
which we'll address soon.
And also multiple times per week in our
discord, we have open discussions for
education and research.
So if this is all a lot or you're not
sure about anything, probably the best
way to just drop in and find out would be
to check out when and how we're meeting
and come to the open discussions.
If you just want to see what's up.
Anything you want to add there, Alex?
Alex: Good to see that projects are
active and mostly maybe for last period
of time.
It's having that new courses which we'll
describe later, but having and feeling is
growing.
It provides great opportunities for
second half of the year.
Daniel: So true, in the first quarterly
roundtable, we had no courses, but as of
now, we can say that there are two
courses that are really pushing the
frontier of education and even research
in quantum information sciences and in
social sciences.
So thanks again.
We'll get to those soon.
All right, let's dive into a little more
detail on active.
So, Alex, would you like to first
introduce and give a little thoughts on
the active inference qualification system
draft?
Alex: Yeah, we put it here, like for now
at education adjective scale, but future
it will be applied for all institute
structure and activities.
We should have some cornerstone in terms
of how we can measure effectiveness of
our educational activities and
educational services in the beginning, to
understand courses and our materials, how
we change actually someone's mind and how
deep this mind need to be changed in some
formal sense.
And we not started from Greenfield.
We just take one of stable system of
qualifications level from European and
adopt it for how we can see it in
application to active inference and
participations in projects and so on.
And for now, we have a basic draft and we'
'll have discussions around with
interested parties, different scales of
institute, and finally have some stable
form which will apply to different
direction.
Daniel: Thanks.
I'll just add a few notes on this first,
just echoing your last point.
If you're interested in active inference,
professionalization education,
qualification systems, even as a critic,
we would really love to have you in the
game.
So please participate early, participate
often.
And I'll just highlight a few pieces of
this system draft that are really
exciting.
First, it begins at level zero, which
everybody de facto can have, perhaps even
upon or before birth.
Then, as the levels proceed, active
inference is always being connected with
domains and systems of interest.
So it's about yes, and with active
inference about connecting active
inference to other fields and topics,
understanding a different domain's
ontology robotics or neuroscience or pure
mathematics, whatever it may be.
And working with active inference as you
gain knowledge of the ontology and of the
details of active inference.
But it's not just a knowledge based
qualification system.
We also are looking to integrate skills
and even project responsibility and
autonomy.
So just to give kind of an example of
this, levels one and two, again,
currently very tentative drafts, so for
your engagement.
But in levels one and two, people are
able to act as basic learners and
collaborators and begin to get a grasp on
what terms we're using in active
inference and how do those concepts
relate to their field of interest.
And we see this every single day in the
textbook group.
And in discussions, someone says, oh, I'm
working as a physical therapist.
And so in action, that's like the person
moving their arm.
That is where these levels are targeted.
Level three begins to get into describing
and understanding some of the technical
details of what we do.
Level four begins to approach the
evaluation and recapitulation of
technical models in active inference.
Level five is related to comprehensive
development and implementation, as well
as in the projects and autonomy, exerting
more supervision for self and others.
Level six, developing advanced skills.
Level seven, engaging with very
specialized problem solving skills.
And level eight, engaging in synthesis,
evaluation and critical problem solving.
So again, can't emphasize enough it's
just a draft, and we are calling for your
participation if this is something that
you would be interested in using or
engaging with.
But we think this is going to be a really
important direction for the active
inference ecosystem carrying on to the
textbook group.
So in the active inference textbook group,
, we are working on and through the Par,
Pazulo and Friston 2022 textbook.
Currently we have cohort three working on
the second half of the book and cohort
four on the first half of the book.
Together, these two cohorts compromise
about 150 people.
Not every person joins every meeting.
Some people engage with the recordings
asynchronously other people are in our
shared epistemic niche, just gleaning and
contributing to this kind of
collaborative stigmaergic process.
As educators, we're focused on the
continual delivery and deployment of
questions and enrichment and discourse in
just some ways that this plays out.
Here are, for example, questions that
people have asked live or before or after
a synchronous meeting where we can
connect the specific figures and the
ontology terms to people's uncertainties.
.
And on the right is an example of an
equation.
Here's the variational free energy
equation 2.5, and the way that we can use
the ontology to unpack and connect some
of the dots with these equations.
And in the last few weeks, we've actually
taken that even further and explored how
to use language models through Coda AI in
this process.
So here we have Equations 2.1 and
Equations 2.2.
They are being rendered in Coda via
typing in LaTech.
And then we are using language models
within Coda to provide explanations,
contextualizations for different
backgrounds and expertises, and also
translation into different languages,
describing the variables and the notation
and the who, what and why.
So this has been a pretty fun avenue and
a really cool example of how language
models and education can be hand in hand
and empower our own learning by using all
kinds of models to help us, where frankly,
, it can be quite challenging, which is
in understanding some of the analytical
details of the framework.
Anything you want to add, Alex?
Alex: This is that type of technology
which looks like magic, but having in
place ontology, which is nicely
integrated for Coda again to all projects.
.
It's really like an engine for this car
which is getting more and more speed.
Cool.
Daniel: Okay, in May 2023, we began our
first course at the Institute, and that
was Physics as Information Processing,
being taught by one of the leading
researchers in the area, Chris Fields,
and with a Math PhD course assistant,
Andre Agira.
So Chris, thank you for stepping up again
from the Scientific Advisory Board to
offer this truly incredible and unique
educational experience.
We've had massive response, dozens of
registrants who want to engage in the
participatory discussions that happen in
between your lectures, the second
discussion being tomorrow for those who
want to join, and 1500 views of the first
lecture in a month.
There's many people who are following
along the course.
Syllabus is explicit and innovative.
We have a question and answer system so
that people can ask questions
asynchronously Chris then answers them.
And we have them posted again through
this interactive Coda interface.
And that's really supporting an
incredible level of discourse and
participation.
All transcripts are going to be curated
and published along with the questions
and answers and some other supplemental
information.
So this has been a really great
experience and something new over the
last few months.
Anything you want to add, I'm tempted to
just talk about how cool the quantum
information free energy principle is.
But perhaps now is not the moment.
Alex: For me historically, for my fault,
the ground starting from beginning on
this century, starting from It technology
technologies and computer science and
this notion of information processing.
It always was like in engineering sense,
like working field and working domain.
But I always had that need and feeling
for first principles and for physics in
place.
And for now, seeing that latest
development on quantum information theory
and how it nicely connects to free energy
and active inference, it's really great
to have these frontier curves in place in
our activities.
And really great thanks to Chris and
ander and I believe that it's kind of
starting point maybe ten years after we'
'll come back altogether and discuss how
this course started.
Great changes for different ecosystems.
Daniel: Thank you, Alex.
Totally agree.
And also we are fresh off the presses,
happy to announce the second course that
we'll be offering at the institute, which
is Constructing Cultural Landscapes
Active Inference for the Social Sciences.
.
And this is going to be a multi teacher
massively participatory course avel of
Cairos Research.
Thank you for taking the initiative to
suggest even this possibility.
And Ben and Mahault Lorena, thanks a lot
for joining on for the journey.
On July 7, we will begin and it will have
some lecture sessions as well as
participatory discussion sections.
All sessions are free.
They'll be live streamed and rewatchable.
.
The transcripts will be curated and
published into a book at the end of the
year.
And this is going to be a really great on
ramp and space for people with a
humanities or social sciences background.
.
So we've heard people waiting for such a
thing.
It was Avel's insight that such a course
could be hosted at Cairos Research and at
the Active Inference Institute.
So thanks to all the teachers here and
just really looking forward to how you
tackle and engage with this question of
active inference in the social sciences.
Anything you want to add?
Alex: Yeah, like these two different
courses, like from different two distinct
scales, like from quantum scale and
social scale.
And possibly it's like two different ends
of spectrum in which we can work on with
our research and education.
It's great that this step to social
sciences because it brings active
inference and it's formal and first
principles principled framework into the
domain which haven't got it before and
now it's a great begin also.
And our scales between quantum and social
will be on us to work on next years.
Daniel: Yes, and the kind of oroborous or
horseshoe theory with quantum social
sciences onto the live streams.
So, lot to say, of course, a little bit
meta since we're on a live stream right
now.
But I'll just note a few things.
First, across our different series, we
now have 336 completed or planned live
streams.
So most of those have already happened,
but there are several that are planned,
but we're over 300 completed and 336 as
of now being planned.
And even just specifically looking at the
next 30 days, we have just such a breadth
and depth it's quite exciting to watch,
let alone to enact.
We'll have the Chris Fields course, a
discussion section, a lecture and then
another discussion section.
We'll begin the active inference for the
social sciences course with Avel Ben
having contributions.
We'll have a guest stream with professors
from around the world, researchers, all
these different topics being able to be
slotted in with a really great way to
platform and give visibility and catalyze
discussion around these incredible
researchers work.
So it's really exciting and it would be
great.
Not going to say it's specifically a
personal request, but if you choose to
read it as such then great.
It would be awesome to have more
assistance with participating and
preparing and enacting live streams.
We have role based ways of planning and
So whether you want to play a more
technical or operational or logistical
role, if you want to be a conversational
facilitator, if you want to do it in a
different language, if you want to do a
series, there's so many ways that you can
get involved.
But it would just be awesome to have more
voices on the live stream and just be
able to continue offering these kinds of
resources at even faster rate with
increased professionalization.
And I know that there's many people out
there who would be incredible
contributors to broadcast and or
facilitate.
Everyone is also welcome to self nominate
or suggest or introduce somebody who you
think would fit well on a stream.
If it's like a perspective that we haven'
't heard from, that would be really
important.
There's a lot of background technical and
educational work on the zero videos when
we do a paper discussion.
So if there's a paper that you want to
have a million X leveraged contribution
on your preparation around, if we discuss
that in a live stream and you're able to
help before with the zero, you'll be a co.
.
Author on a research publication of the
transcript and you'll have made an
absolutely unique, irreplaceable
contribution to active inference
knowledge with what you did in your
diligence in the zero.
So for people who hear that calling, that'
's incredibly important.
We invite people to share the live
streams on social media or with their
colleagues, however they find it relevant.
.
Like if there's a topic or a person that
has come up on our streams, sharing it
where relevant will help bring people in.
.
And also we have weekly live stream
meetings.
So if you just want to find out what we
do and how we do it in the live streams,
then I would recommend that you join the
regular meetings.
And if you really want to join but that
time never works for you, then email and
let us know that you're specifically
interested.
We'll find a different time.
Any other comments there Alex?
Alex: For this moment, we can see that a
lot of Livestream activity is happening
with participation of people, not only
with our own preparations, but with
people who just want to share this and so
on.
And if we can keep this written to having
different people with their interests and
sharing ideas, and yes, if people will
join to help us to do it more and more
often, maybe it will be great.
Daniel: Thank you.
The active inference journal picks up
where live stream stops.
The Active Inference Journal is engaged
in continuous deployment and development
of speech to text transcription,
automated and manual editing, curation
and finally publication.
So just to give an example, a live stream
will occur and then we use speech to text
onto a public GitHub repository.
Everybody can edit the markdown file and
then we're able to publish those
transcripts so that they can be citable,
so that a conversation someone has can go
onto their resume as a true citable
publication and we can just facilitate
the accessibility and the findability of
these incredible conversations and
moments that we have.
And also in the active inference journal.
.
We're always developing the process from
setup for those of all technical
backgrounds.
How to get things working on your own
local setup or on a cloud setup using
free and open source software where
possible.
The speech to text, the text processing
the editing, translating into languages,
rendering into a diversity of formats,
publishing through different channels and
then engaging in further analysis related
to natural language processing and the
active inference ontology all these fun
things we can do.
So if you in an alternate multiverse, we'
're a librarian or an editor or a
reviewer or an advocate of the Active
Inference corpus, bring it into this
reality and make a huge contribution by
cultivating our epistemic garden and our
offerings.
Because there's so much enrichment that
can happen with past streams and with
proactively, letting the live stream
project know and letting courses know how
we can help them at the Journal to
develop these kinds of publications that
in new ways are expanding definitions of
scholarship and research and service.
Anything else to add?
Alex: Yeah, as for this project, I
believe it's like most technical heavy in
the institute and maybe we can call it
more broadly like language Processing
project and maybe it is a good starting
point for people who have good technical
skills, some programming skills which are
related to language processing in general
or some specific part of it.
Maybe it will be of interest for them to
start from this project and later get
better grasp on what is active influence
is awesome.
Daniel: Totally agree.
It's like seeing the range of live
streams is really one of the best ways to
just jump into understanding the ways and
the topics that people speak.
Okay, we'll just briefly mention the
research work happening, but this last
several month period has been extremely
focused and extremely productive on
education with the two new courses, the
qualification system, all of these other
curricular developments.
So there's several ongoing research
projects.
We have the active inference ontology as
a research and development initiative,
active blockference as a software package
for complex systems modeling using active
inference robotics and embodied with JF's
symbolic active inference robots.
And then there's some project seeds that
we always love to offer up to interns or
to volunteers as something that they can
restart and take a lot of initiative,
something that's just planted but barely
there.
And that right now is the graphical
interface with thinking really
expansively about what it looks like to
learn and apply active inference from an
embodied perspective.
And cognitive agent modeling, doing
metaanalysis and synthesis across
different cognitive modeling frameworks
so that we can really have a place to
point when we describe how different
cognitive phenomena speaking to a
cognitive pattern language are
implemented or addressed by active
inference and other frameworks.
And then there's the so many of you who
engage in individual research.
So there's a lot of research happening in
the space, and we see education as a
fundamental enablement for research as
part of the institute's mission for
education and research development.
So it's been good times with research,
and I'm really excited to see all the
projects that people share during
sessions start to develop and flourish.
Anything else you want to add about
research, Alex?
Alex: Yeah, maybe this direction was not
so active last time, but as we discussed
for future directions, that we will bring
more attention and more efforts to maybe
formalize a bit how we as institute can
survive people around from ecosystems,
how we can support them on their ways and
so on.
So it will be good times here, too.
Daniel: Yeah, agreed.
We want to provide a lot of research
services, so for people who want to be on
any side of that table, reach out.
All right, well, the last section here is
going to be a short active inference
based presidential address.
I will be just speaking to some recent
developments as well as past developments
in the active inference space and just
give a few thoughts on how they relate to
the active inference institute and what
we're all doing here.
If you're watching live, please write
some questions or comments into the live
chat.
And at the end of this short address, we
will review any other comments or
questions from those who are here live,
give some last thoughts, and then we'll
be back into the work.
So I wanted to begin this address with a
reference to the work that was before
active inference institute, which was
active inference lab.
But even before active inference lab,
there was the collaboration with Alex,
Ivan, Alexandra, RJ, and myself around
active inference and behavior engineering
for teams and organizations.
And this was in.
September 2020, only a few years ago, now
more than two, but less than three years
ago.
And it's amazing how far things have come
and at the same time how many of the
topics that we were able to bring into
this context of remote teams and
organizations still ring as relevant and
they're just gestured to here.
We've gone far towards enacting and
implementing and improving, but still we
can think about cognitive entities
engaged in the cyberphysical niche with
narrative and rhetoric structuring their
understanding of how sensory data
translate into action.
So for people who are interested in this
topic, we invite you one way or another
to engage with us on this journey because
we are only going to do it all together.
So I just wanted to begin with that kind
of callback to several years ago, though
so much has changed, certainly for all of
us in the times between that when we
really find first principles approaches
like active inference and when we really
care about systems of interest and
communities, then the actions that we
take, we don't regret.
But I think we can go into a little bit
more detail and reference some recent
developments in the active inference
ecosystem that speak to how day after day,
, week after week, our system of interest,
, active inference, learning and
application really gifts or blesses us
with new ways of thinking and new ways of
acting.
So for example, just within the last
months, the inner screen model of
consciousness was released as a preprint
by Maxwell Ramstead et al.
Dealing with all these topics that we
know and love and building upon the
quantum free energy principle formalism,
which again, it's easy to forget, was not
even in place two years ago.
Discussed in Live stream number 40 and
weeks after publication, we're able to
enact a conversation hearing from voices
all over the world, bringing experts and
those with different backgrounds onto the
screen.
Here, the screen that you see is the
classical information depository that
enables us as quantum cognitive agents to
engage with each other.
And so all of these beautiful people on
the stream who with their regime of
attention and their quantum cognitive
rotation brought to bear their attention
and their language contribution through
action, we are able to inscribe that on
classical digital artifacts like live
streams and transcripts and then provide
it to the niche for all of you to rotate
that into your own space and context.
So again, the spatial, temporal and
conceptual linkages are happening at a
speed that is boggling.
And on the right is a paper from just
this month officially by Thomas Parr et
al.
Cognitive effort and active inference.
And I have the image small because there'
's more details to go into in the paper.
However, they used a well known model of
cognitive burden called a Stroop model,
which shows a color written out as a word
and that word is shown in some color.
So the color red written in red, the
color red written in blue, and the timing
dynamics of people's reading behavior and
recognition behavior is a proxy for
cognitive effort.
And so this is just one more, not even
brick in the wall, not even just one tool
in the toolkit, but like another lens or
layer or ability or capacity for active
inference framework which adds these
features affect, memory, anticipation.
All these different features are layered
in like a symphony without developing
Bloat, because the first principles
kernel, the cognitive firmware, is not
getting Bloated, it is staying at first
principles.
And sometimes it feels like even diving
down to zero with principles.
While advanced research in the space is
able to help us understand really
sophisticated cognitive phenomena like
cognitive effort, now one can look back
through the previous stream and what we
discussed and how could cognitive effort
help us support the accessibility, rigor
and applicability of active inference?
It's such a natural question and again,
week after week, our niche provides us
with new ways of thinking and doing.
So it's so fun to be gripping and gripped
within active inference.
I'd like to recognize and commend jacob's,
, excellent work.
Just in April, we published Generalized
Notation notation for active inference
models.
GNN generalized notation notation is a
plain text format for conveying active
inference generative models.
It's something like a dialect of markdown
and it brings us closer and closer to the
triple play.
The triple play is the idea that we
should have integrity amongst multiple
representations of active inference
models.
That is, what we see visualized
graphically or tangibly what we hear and
say in terms of the natural language use
and with executable cognitive simulations.
.
So if someone looks at an organizational
flowchart and there's three A's connected
to two B's, that is something that we can
visualize, describe and execute so that
there isn't a front and a back room
conversation.
Rather, there's an integrated
conversation that allows for everybody to
make contributions in the modalities and
in the ways that they want.
And the interlingua, not the only
interlingua, and by no means its final
version is the plain text generalized
notation notation.
We're having a lot of fun working with
language models and visualizing this,
transforming it into executable
simulations.
And so thanks again, Yakup, for the
really creative and dedicated work
because this method is going to be a real
core functionality for translating across
visual elements, our natural languages
and the kinds of simulations that we want
to run.
And I'll close with a recent publication
with Karl Friston et al., including
myself and Bleu.
So two out of three officers on the paper,
, not terrible.
And in this paper we used free energy
principle and active inference to provide
something like a measuring or an
observability framework for ecology,
evolution and development or ecoevo devo.
.
And the way that this was done is through
the Renormalization group of physics.
And so in this image on the left, we can
see it as like maybe a bunch of cells
which each contain organelles and those
cells make a tissue.
Or the big circle might be the population
of organisms or the ecosystem community.
Again, recognizing the nested niche
engagement within and across levels of
spatial and temporal modeling and looking
at just two layers and how they're
connected, we can think of that as a
nested action perception cycle.
So here's, like the sensory and the
behavior of a worm, in this case,
happening at whatever timescale it's
being modeled at, and then at the slower
or the deeper level of the hierarchical
model, we have the Bayesian learning like
process of the extended genotype
happening in a slower adaptive layer.
And so this should clearly connect to
what we said at the very beginning of the
stream about the institute as part of a
nested system.
Here we have the ecosystem, the space
around here's, the institute.
This is what it really means to enter and
to join, not just to look into, but to be
on or in the institute.
And then the kinds of dynamic partitions
that we're able to embody within the
institute through our communications and
through our actions.
And so it's just so exciting to see
everyone's incredible research
contributions, the kinds of questions and
developments that even if I were not an
author, even if I were not in the active
inference field, I would believe are at
least the right things to be trying in
terms of bringing theoretical integration
in ecology, evolution and development.
At least these are the right research
avenues.
But then again, to be able to act infer
and serve through the institute as a
multiscale evolutionary entity in and of
itself, this kind of real time enactment
of multiple scales and quantum reference
frames is something that is only arising
through cocreation.
So in closing, I send my deepest
appreciation to all those who support and
care and engage.
To those who are not sure, I welcome you
to the past, the present and the future
we respect and that's why we do what we
do.
So Alex, where do we go or what is next?
Alex: Yeah, thank you very much for the
talk and really providing that vision
from the beginning and how it's going now
and congratulations on that publication
on evolutionary work.
And it's a great opening direction and I
believe this direction will make a next
step into technical evolution also.
And we will use this technique, evolution
approach to develop institute candidacy
system.
Daniel: Yes, I'll just wait a few more
seconds.
If anyone writes a question that we can
address in the live chat, let's look at
some of these questions that we look at
at the end of every live stream.
What would a good understanding enable?
Well, if we were able to really
understand our own generative model as
the institute and as the active inference
ecosystem, it would support our sense
making and decision making.
We'd be able to act and infer and serve
better.
What are the unique predictions and
implications?
That's a very interesting question.
I'm sure there are many ways to address
this and we did have many future oriented
expressions during this discussion, even
today.
What are the next steps for free energy
principle and active inference?
Again, do you have any thoughts on this
one?
The middle question or the second
question?
Alex.
Alex: Delivered and unique predictions
and next steps depends on some specific
field or domain for ourselves.
We understand that active inference is a
scale free approach and it can be applied
to any scale of research.
Any domain which any researcher or
engineer is working on can be described
with active inference language starting
from where using accordances to
computational modeling or types of
modeling and so on.
Yeah.
Daniel: What are the goals of the
research?
To embody our mission to support the
active inference ecosystem, to be the
best institute we can be, be the best
nest mates within it.
What do you think?
Alex: Maybe we should remove goals.
Daniel: Let's change it to preferences.
Alex: Yeah, at least.
And considering it in open endedness way.
.
Again, we can speak about goals, but
looks like it's not so useful concept.
Daniel: Yes, sometimes when we're talking
about the specific research papers, we
talk about the goal of that paper, but
goal is not to be found in the active
inference ontology and we find ways of
making do and thriving without needing to
rest upon goals and reward.
And that's really exciting.
And that's something that a lot of people
don't even realize that they're steeped
in reward maximization and goal
implementation until the open endedness
and the vitality of active inference
becomes understood.
What are you still curious about?
I'll let you go first, then I'll give a
last thought.
As we close.
Alex: I always remember our discussions
about sense of the word curious in the
beginning.
It's like I believe more and more curious
with week each day, each month.
What our field, our frontier are showing
us so much, a lot of different
perspectives, different connections, real
people in communications and projects and
so on.
So it's happiness.
Daniel: Very beautiful.
I'm curious about many things like that.
You said that we develop and hone that
curiosity every day and we seek to spark
and be sparked when people come in from
different backgrounds with their
curiosities.
It's inspiring, to say the least.
And I'm really curious about who will
have listened or read this far in the
stream and choose that moment to take an
action to get involved with the institute.
.
So there's only one way that my
uncertainty is going to be reduced about
that.
And I think if you know, you know.
So.
Thank you, Alex.
Thank you, .
Thank you to the officers and to all of
the institute.
See you around.
Alex: Thank you.
Thank you.